gas today is 52
more expensive than it was at this same
time last year the price of eggs is up
at least 23
the cost of milk is up 38
in just one year
and i would bet that your income has not
gone up 23 or 38 or 52
actually there's a good chance you lost
your job after politicians shut your
country down for two years of two weeks
to slow the spread of a virus that
almost certainly does not pose any
serious threat to you
the inflation rate overall is 7.9
percent the highest it's been in 40
years and if you're concerned about how
you're going to make ends meet well
you're just a big stupid ingrate
according to joe biden
never forget what we've accomplished
together
so far
and by the way the american people just
trying to stay above water don't
understand this
you tell them what the american recovery
act was they look at you like what are
you talking about
they don't understand it that's true
they don't understand it because it
doesn't make any sense they don't
understand it because if biden's
economic policies were working americans
wouldn't be struggling to stay above
water in the first place
they don't understand it because if
biden had any sense left in that dusty
old noggin he wouldn't be admitting how
bad things have gotten on his watch
but he doesn't know what he's saying
he doesn't know what he's doing he
certainly doesn't know how to fix it and
at least in theory he's got three years
left to make everything even worse i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from marcus w who says
it's a hard stint in prison when you're
sharing a cell with your attacker while
in solitary confinement that is really
tough for jesse smallett you know it
does seem cruel i want the man brought
to justice but it does seem cruel to
make him share a cell with his attacker
that's a problem he should have planned
ahead okay he really should have
invested in himself and not not tried to
create all of these ridiculous
distractions you know and when you want
to bank on yourself i would recommend
you check out bank on yourself right now
you've got to go to bankonyourself.com
knowles do you really control your
retirement money if you've got a 401k or
ira or similar retirement plan the
government controls it they decide how
much you can borrow and when you must
pay it back and you'll owe taxes and
penalties for taking money out too soon
or waiting too long even though it's
your money and thanks to our
skyrocketing national debt who knows how
much you'll have to pay in taxes during
a retirement that could last 30 years
bank on yourself is a better way to grow
and protect your hard-earned money
guaranteed predictable growth and
retirement income with no luck skill or
guesswork required in fact bank on
yourself has a 160-year plus track
record of positive growth tax-free
retirement income you'll know what your
tax rate will be in retirement zero
under current tax law which protects you
from the coming tax tsunami you are in
control you have control of your money
without government penalties or
restrictions on how much income you can
take for when you can take it you can
get a free report right now with all the
details on how adding bank on yourself
to your financial plan can help you take
back control of your money go to bank
onyself.com knowles that's
bankonyourself.com knowles canadawlis
this information is for educational
purposes only and it's not a
solicitation for the purchase of any
financial product all guarantees are
based on the claims paying ability of
the insurer
i was thinking over the weekend
about
joe biden's conundrum okay because he's
wrong ideologically he's wrong
he's wrong on the kinds of people he's
made investments in
his staff members the politicians who
are supporting him
the people he's investing in overseas
you know trying to suck up to iran
irritating our enemies sucking
irritating our allies rather sucking up
to our enemies he's he's made a lot of
ideological
problems
so has kamala so have others
but there's also the issue of basic
competence
in these jobs when you are when you're
running a lemonade stand much less when
you're running a country you need to
have a basic level of competence you
need to know the really basic things
about how your economy operates about
how
you create incentives and disincentives
for certain behaviors about how to deal
with certain actors on a global stage if
you don't have that basic level of
competence things are going to get
really bad and right now kamala harris
has been sent on the lost cause tour
biden always sends kamala harris to deal
with issues that have no solution that
he's totally given up on most famously
he did it at the southern border now the
fact that he's sending her to eastern
europe to deal with this ukraine issue
is really bad news for the ukrainians
because it means he has absolutely no
faith that ukraine is going to remain a
country
he's he clearly is 100 betting that
russia has already conquered ukraine so
he sends kamala over there kamala is
asked a question about
domestic issues gas prices inflation how
much longer do we understand that war is
having something to do with this but
kamala how much longer are we going to
have to deal with this
she shrugs her shoulders
president biden has said that americans
will feel some pain for the sake of
defending freedom and liberty
but there does seem to be no end game in
sight
how long should americans expect how
long should we be bracing for
this really sort of
historic inflation and some
unprecedented gas prices
in terms of uh the discussions that the
president
johannes and i had they ranged in
subject including the issue of the black
sea and i'll let him
explain in more detail as he would like
but
we are again
fully aware and apprised because we are
in constant communication
with the president with his
administration here
about the concerns that they have about
the entire region and frankly the
vulnerability
all you have to do is look at the map
what what what
the question was about gas prices and
she
the reporter asks her the question about
gas prices and there's just dead silence
she says uh
and then she looks to the president of
romania as if
as if he's going to answer the question
about american domestic gas prices for
her
uh oh okay i'll take this one okay you
okay president of romania you don't need
to take the question that was directly
asked of me about american domestic
politics uh we're here
and we're doing things with romania and
we're and you've got not it's so
pathetic
even if you don't have an answer
because there is no answer because the
answer is that the biden administration
needs to completely reverse all of its
energy policies but even if you don't
have the answer be prepared for the
question this is really
basic issues
of competence this is like read a memo
kind of basic preparation to do your
very very important job this this wasn't
even the most egregious example of this
overseas kamala harris
is now addressing
the crisis in ukraine what this means as
russia is expanding what it means for
europe
the nato alliance don't forget the
central issue in this ukraine war is
will ukraine join nato will ukraine join
the european union
ukraine right now
is ostensibly a neutral country it has
cozied up to russia in the past and then
ever since the government was ousted in
2014 it's cozied up much more to the
west it it presumably wants to join nato
nato has not accepted it yet and here's
kamala harris giving her genius expert
medernikian view
of the geopolitical situation
so
i will say what i know we all say and i
will say over and over again
the united states stands firmly with the
ukrainian people in defense of the nato
alliance
the united states stands with the
ukrainian people in defense of the nato
alliance the ukrainian people are not in
the nato alliance that's
that's the whole issue
that's the whole problem if you don't
know that ukraine is not in nato then
you don't know anything about the war in
ukraine
and this is not just some offhand
comment kamala harris was doing a town
hall in idaho and she gets asked a
question that she doesn't know about
this is kamala harris being sent to
eastern europe specifically to address
the war in ukraine she doesn't know the
most basic fact about the war in ukraine
she they just don't know things
you know you know the thing to quote joe
biden they don't they don't know the
thing
so is it any wonder
that nothing is going their way
i am all for the high level
sophisticated ideological debates the
the questions of grand strategy of what
is going to advance america's interests
i'm all for that but you need to know
really basic stuff before you can answer
those questions it's like saying we're
going to have very sophisticated
conversations about calculus but we
don't know that two plus two equals four
you need to this is the consequence of
an education system that says you don't
need to know facts you just need to know
broad themes we're not going to teach
you what to think we're just going to
teach you how to think well you know
let's teach some basic facts okay where
is bucharest
where is kiev
what two plus two equals what you need
you need to know these basic things
before you can go there and
it's as though we've got a government
that is play acting
their version of the west wing
this is not a government that is
actually dealing with
geopolitical realities this is a
government that was raised watching the
west wing and then they go into office
and then they just talk like they heard
aaron sorkin right on the west wing and
they think that that is going to bring
peace to the world it's not it's
bringing on world war iii before there
should be a rule before you get elected
president or vice president you need to
know what countries are in nato okay
you need to know what makes gas prices
go up and down you need there should be
a basic test here
but we didn't used to need this okay
there used to be a much better level of
competence in our government that is
gone
okay and there there are
there are unintended consequences of
this kind of stuff all right because
right now the the
the west's strategy on putin and ukraine
is we're gonna cancel russia
we're just going to cancel russia we're
not going to send any soldiers in well
that would be we're not going to
establish a no-fly zone that would be
too provocative we don't want to provoke
vladimir putin he's a nuclear former
superpower we don't want to do that so
instead we're going to completely
destroy their economy we're going to
sanction their central bank this is an
unprecedented war tactic we're going to
get every company on planet earth
to stop doing with business with russia
and that's going to make us feel really
good
and we're not going to send soldiers
into harm's way so we're going to feel
really good about that too and we're not
going to go directly to war
so we're going to feel really good about
that too we're just going to turn russia
into a rogue state completely destroy
their society and then hope that
everything turns out for the best what
then what then what do we expect is
going to happen next probably nothing
because no one running our country is
thinking even more than two weeks into
the future now when you want to think
into the future specifically your
financial future you've got to check out
birch gold inflation is now at 7.8
percent thanks to build back broke and
other biden policies which means that
that paper money in your wallet is
losing value fast and russia's
full-scale invasion of ukraine has now
worsened the market's slow decline today
an ounce of gold is worth nineteen
hundred bucks it was worth about three
hundred dollars per ounce in the year
two thousand i have been telling you for
years and years now that you can buy
gold from birch gold it's your hedge
against inflation did you know that
there's another way to hedge against
inflation
silver silver and gold you can get
silver from birch gold silver is also
considered real money historically
speaking it's extremely undervalued
right now it's an industrial metal it's
in high demand for everything from
electric cars to solar panels that
demand is only going to rise and some
analysts suggest suggest that there is
an unusual dislocation in price that may
present very real opportunities for
silver to rally over the next two years
i've really enjoyed investing in silver
right now you can call birch gold
they're the only company that i trust uh
do not wait text knowles k-w-l-e-s to 98
98 98 to get a free info kit on buying
gold or silver in a tax sheltered
account no obligation to get this info
text knowles k wlas
989898 to get your free info kit now
so all the companies on planet earth are
canceling russia
this is the first hashtag social media
cancel culture campaign that we have
ever seen applied to a
country okay
most countries in the world have
something to do
with the nation-state system most
countries in the world have something to
do with the ordinary world order even
iran
the world's largest state sponsor of
terror for the past half century they've
had one foot into the international
order one foot out of it on the one hand
they do business like an ordinary nation
on the other hand they support
terrorists to upend
all sorts of international stability
okay
but still even iran is kind of in it
north korea might be the example of a
state that is almost entirely outside of
the international system and yet north
korea is basically just propped up by
china they're a sort of quasi proxy
state for china but now
we are taking russia
the former soviet union
the
world's nuclear former
one of the two superpowers
and we are turning russia into north
korea all these businesses are stopped
stopping their business in russia
and so what's going to happen
putin might just take the businesses
we might be getting the soviet union all
over again vladimir putin is threatening
to nationalize the businesses that are
no longer doing business in russia
he says if businesses cease operations
in russia and at least a quarter of
their stock belongs to any country
designated an unfriendly nation
such as
the united states or almost any country
on earth now the government will place
the business under the control of a
state-owned development organization if
companies do not resume operations
within five days or agree to sell their
business will be placed under external
control for three months then sold at
auction if no one buys it at auction the
state is the buyer and so the government
just takes over the companies just like
has happened in every communist
revolution
the unintended consequence of all these
companies canceling russia is we might
just get the soviet union right back
same old state-owned
government-run command control type of
economy
probably
biden didn't see that coming probably
the ceos who canceled russia didn't see
that coming the whole idea of just
pulling all your business out of a
country
in order to influence that country
that's a bizarre idea because for the
past what 50 years or more than 50 years
70 or 80 years we have been told that
corporations need to go into hostile
countries that that's actually how we're
going to exert our influence
you know they'll say
no two countries with a mcdonald's have
ever gone to war with each other that
was always the sort of neo-liberal
globalist mantra so what do they do
right before we're about to go to war
with russia mcdonald's ceases operations
because that way it's still true no two
countries at the mcdonald's have gone to
war with each other mcdonald's ran out
beforehand we need to spread coca-cola
all around the world this is american
soft cultural power this is how we're
going to spread our influence well if
that's true then how come all these
companies are all pulling their
their product out right now
i don't even think it's to influence
russia i think it's because of the fa
the fad of cancer culture because
coca-cola knows that its customers
demand that it pulls out of russia or
mcdonald's or
whichever of these companies
and so you're seeing a cascading
cancellation well we might feel really
good about that yeah take that putin
yeah you don't get your hamburger
anymore take that
but what is the unintended consequence
oh the unintended consequences you might
now have this state going completely
rogue nationalizing companies giving us
a brand new cold war is that smart
i don't think so it's also
it happens because of this misconception
that the west is omnipotent that we can
do whatever we want all we need to do is
do it show strength
this
the west is very powerful
but the west is not omnipotent okay
this was the same backwards thinking
that made us think oh we'll go into iraq
it'll take three weeks they'll greet us
as liberators it'll be all over we'll
install a madisonian democracy and then
everyone will live happily ever after is
that what happened in iraq no
same thing about egypt oh we'll go in
we'll get rid of mo of of
not moammar gadhafi of hosni mubarak who
was a long-time ally of the united
states we'll get rid of mubarak he's no
longer politically convenient we'll find
somebody else they'll have a democracy
they'll live happily ever after did that
happen no same thing in libya
we're gonna go into libya get rid of
gaddafi and then it's gonna be a
wonderful thriving democracy right wrong
that didn't happen we'll go into syria
we'll go in here we couldn't even
occupy afghanistan indefinitely
afghanistan is this backwood backwater
place full of largely illiterate goat
herders we occupied it for 20 years we
didn't change a damn thing on the ground
the second we left the afghan military
collapsed the so-called democracy we
have there collapsed the taliban came
right back in this is not to say that
the west is powerless or impotent but
our hubris really gets the better of us
sometimes okay and we think that
whatever we want to do we can do and
it'll be cost free it'll be easy it'll
be fast just go in and do it well some
sometimes
it's more complicated
sometimes you need to know really basic
things about
about the countries that you're invading
really basic things about the policies
you're pursuing if you
really want to outfox vladimir putin
who's a very shrewd political operative
if you really want to remake the entire
area of eastern europe
how about you know which countries are
in nato huh
if you really want to get into this war
over oil and energy with russia and iran
and other other hostile actors how about
you know the basic elements of what
makes gas prices go up and down if you
don't do that if you just think we're
the west we can do whatever we want we
don't need to read a basic textbook
about how to do this then things are not
going to go
very well for you lots of you want to
know the perfect example of these
unintended consequences
last week you will remember
i was a crazy kooky
putin
talking point spewing tin foil
hat-wearing conspiracy theorist because
i pointed out that the
russian and chinese propaganda about bio
labs in ukraine in conjunction with the
united states military
actually
exist and initially the
west's propaganda and the pentagon and
the white house they denied that these
bio labs existed then they said okay
maybe they do exist but we don't really
have much to do with them okay well yeah
maybe we have an association but it's
for ordinary scientific research okay
yeah well maybe the military is running
things but
look there's no worry about bio weapons
here this is totally above board so over
the weekend on the sunday shows
the pentagon
told a cbs reporter
yes
actually we are very very worried that
because these bio labs exist and because
the russians are coming in you might
have a bio weapons problem in ukraine
russia though is willing to use
munitions that have been banned under
international law we know that we heard
president biden warn about chemical
weapons use
are we seeing movement of those kind of
weapons into ukraine a pentagon official
i talked to this morning said there is
no
movement of chemical weapons
into ukraine at least they're not seeing
the signs of it the concern is that the
russians will seize one of these
biomedical research facilities that
ukraine has where they do research on
deadly pathogens like
botulism and anthrax
seize one of those facilities weaponize
the pathogen and then blame it on
ukraine and the u.s because the u.s has
been providing support for
some of the research being done in those
facilities but
it appears the ukrainians
have gotten most of those pathogens
destroyed
weaponize the pathogens hold up hold on
a second here
you're telling me
that the united states and ukraine do
not have a bio weapons program in these
laboratories that's crazy russian
chinese propaganda how dare you if you
ask any questions about this you're just
a stooge for vladimir putin
but
the fear is that if the russians come in
they'll weaponize the pathogens that are
there now by this statement i don't
think they mean that the russians are
going to go in and create a brand new
bio weapons program right they're not
going to go in and say okay now that
we've got these labs these beakers and
these bunsen burners now we're going to
create a bioweapons program no they're
just going to use
the bio weapons that are already there
but the but the pentagon's argument is
no no all the anthrax and all the deadly
pathogens that we've got there that's
those aren't bio weapons they're only
bio weapons when the russians use them
what are you talking about no if they're
there if they if these pathogens can be
used as bio weapons in these
laboratories that are being run with the
help of the american military then that
is obviously a bio-weapons program
okay and maybe there's perfectly good
reason as to why the united states is
running these labs with ukraine okay i'm
not saying we should buy all of the
conclusions of the russian and chinese
propaganda about what this implies for
public policy
but i don't want my own government lying
to me
and calling me a a liar and a kook and a
conspiracy theorist for pointing out
something that they are now admitting is
true here's what probably happened there
were bioweapons laboratories in the
soviet union after the collapse of the
ussr america comes in takes a lot more
control in eastern europe then we don't
just dismantle these things we keep
running them we're working in connection
with the ukrainian government and with
georgia and with other governments
around the world and we think nothing
bad can ever happen what's the big deal
we're the global hegemon we can do
whatever we want and then whoopsy daisy
war breaks out in ukraine we never
thought it was actually going to happen
even though it was increasingly likely
in recent years i said no it's not going
to happen what could go wrong what could
go wrong what could go wrong well here's
what could go wrong what could go wrong
is now you've got war breaking out in
europe with not only nuclear weapons on
the table but now chemical and
biological weapons too right after right
as we're coming out of a two-year
pandemic that very possibly started in
almost exactly the same way because of a
lab in wuhan china what could go wrong
what could go wrong as if we don't have
basic competence in our political
leaders
you know we've just started our own
publishing wing called daily wire books
we are excited that one of the first
books we'll be publishing is 12 seconds
in the dark by sergeant mattingly the
book is the true story of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
shooting check out this trailer
it was very chaotic it was very quick
instantly i know it was shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
got so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid
the book comes out tomorrow march 15th
it's available for pre-order now on
amazon or anywhere you buy books online
so go get your pre-ordered copy today
because i promise you it will sell out
also if you missed the premiere of the
hyperions do not worry the movie is now
streaming at dailywire.com if you're not
a member yet now is the time to join
plus right now if you join you will be
entered to win the red carpet treatment
with you and the cast and the crew of
terror on the prairie starring gina
carano if you win you'll get flown out
to the red carpet premiere of terror on
the prairie where you will meet and
greet the daily wire folks and the films
cast and crew two lucky members will
each get two tickets and their hotel
flight premier car service and exclusive
merch all on us head on over to
dailywire.com red carpet sign up with
code red carpet and enter this important
contest do not worry if you're already a
member just head on over to
dailywire.com red carpet to enter here
is the trailer for the hyperions
calling all hyperions
[Music]
my name is vista mandelbaum
[Music]
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges
is this real yes ma'am this is real
well i want that too
it's the police they want to talk to
whoever's in charge
[Music]
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
i mean yeah if you think so
calling all hyperions
on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
shots fired
god come on give me my gun
[Applause]
[Applause]
next question how's the family the
family is um
oh
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
head on over to dailywire.com red carpet
enter code red carpet so you don't miss
a beat we will be right back with a lot
more
speaking of unintended consequences in
russia i've got some really good news
for you if you want to make threats
against russians on social media you
know threats on social media against
anybody
are generally frowned upon except right
now facebook has just declared that you
now can allow for posts uh threatening
violence against russians specifically
with regard to ukraine
so this change in policy just came out
from meta platforms it will allow
facebook and instagram users in certain
countries to call for violence against
russians and russian soldiers in the
context of the ukraine invasion now you
can't call for violence against russians
if you say for instance uh i ate my
borscht tonight and some of the red beet
juice splattered on my blazer i'm gonna
kill you russians that is not allowed
but you can say hey i really like
ukraine i want to kill you russians that
is totally fine you've got to be very
specific about what kind of threats of
violence you're making against the
russian people this is according to
internal emails that were seen by
reuters last thursday
this is a temporary change to its hate
speech policy facebook instagram all the
social media companies have hate speech
policies
and
the point of these policies is that hate
will not be tolerated unless mark
zuckerberg wants to tolerate it
hate will not be tolerated on the
platform except when zuckerberg deems it
right
there's a another change that took place
on facebook with regard to ukraine
specifically one of the groups that is
fighting in ukraine is a neo-nazi group
it's called the azov battalion
there are lots of different military and
paramilitary groups fighting in ukraine
but one of them is a neo-nazi group
called the azov battalion you were not
permitted to
support the azov battalion on facebook
that previously violated its hate speech
policy now temporarily during the war in
ukraine you are allowed to make
supportive comments of the neo-nazi
group because that neo-nazi group is
fighting against the russians now by the
way
i totally understand
why depending on the context
facebook would change this hate speech
policy
i totally understand
why they might say that in some cases
it's okay to make comments in support of
nazis and calling for violence against
the russians don't forget in world war
ii we teamed up with russian communists
we in the united states timed up with
teamed up with russian communists to
fight the nazis the communists are no
better than the nazis but the united
states determined it was in our
geopolitical interests to defeat nazi
germany so the way to do it was to team
up with the russian communists we did
that
and then immediately after the second
world war we started another war
with communist russia
that went on and that was called the
cold war so i can understand how in this
case they say look
right now
you got to put your issues with the
nazis aside we've got to team up with
the nazis to fight
the russians who are increasingly
looking like the exact same old russian
communists who are fighting in the cold
war okay
the question for me is
do we trust big tech with this power
if we are going to say that certain
things are going to be censored certain
speech is going to be encouraged even
certain
hate speech is going to be encouraged
even certain direct calls for violence
are going to be encouraged even certain
defenses of neo-nazis are going to be
encouraged now do we trust
big tech to make that call
i don't
certainly not
do we trust big tech not to use this
exact same power this exact same kind of
capriciousness
to say okay now we're going to look at
domestic politics now that we're done
dealing with the nazis in ukraine and
the communists in russia now we're going
to look at those nazis in america you
know those january 6th people
do we not do we not believe that
facebook and youtube and twitter and
google
do we really think they wouldn't use
this power against us to say actually
it's okay to call for certain violence
against certain groups here in america
actually okay it's fine to support
certain violent hate groups here in
america they already do that it's fine
to support antifa it's fine to support
blm antifa and blm spent eight months
burning the country down in 2020.
it's fine to support them
and by the way it's basically tolerated
to to
threaten conservatives on twitter
maybe it's technically against the
letter of the law but rarely will people
get in trouble
for
for defaming insulting even threatening
conservatives who the left believes are
deplorable and irredeemable do we trust
these guys
to have this power i certainly do not
speaking of social media i have got the
creepiest social media story that i have
seen in many many weeks
this goes to the mayor of huntersville
this small little town stacy phillips
mayor of huntersville
sends out a tweet to gay children
asking them to slide into her dms she
says
if you're a kid
living in a don't say gay state and feel
like you don't have an adult to talk to
i got you
you're welcome to slide into my dms to
talk
to share
to express yourself confidentially
it'd be an honor to be your auntie by
blessing
you're perfect just the way you are
i am a very peaceful guy
i am about as chill as they get
even compared to other people in the
conservative movement you know a lot of
conservatives they'll they get really
angry all the time especially
conservative commentators and they yell
and they get really hot in the face and
steam comes out of their ears and that's
not me
okay i am pretty calm i am pretty
peaceable
if
if you
have a private conversation with my
child if you establish a private
relationship with my child specifically
to talk about sex
you better run you better start running
you better run directly to the police to
turn yourself in that would be the best
option for you if there is one thing on
earth that could impel me to violence
that very likely would impel me to
violence
it would be that
hey
hey someone else's kid slide into my dms
it's a very flirtatious phrase
just slide into my dms and we can talk
about your sexual desires i'd love to be
your auntie oh yeah i'm your little
auntie slide on in and we'll talk about
sex
10 year olds 11 year olds 12 year olds
run
run i please we were talking about
threats on social media first of all
that's the craziest threat i ever heard
on social media
that sort of thing
is
extremely creepy and also it's the
logical consequence of this kind of
politics of radical sexual liberation
now in in this woman's defense stacy
phillips
i bet that she did not mean this in a
sexual way i don't who knows maybe she
did maybe she didn't but
i would bet that she didn't i would bet
that she just believes that
sexual liberation is the most important
political battle that we have right now
and parents have no right to raise their
own children
and it's very important that children
pursue whatever sexual desire they have
even if that means mutilating their
bodies even if that means pretending
that they're the different sex and she's
going to be the great liberator
over the oppressive
parents who are who are just keeping
their children constrained you know by
things like the laws of nature
there's a left-wing group together
rising that's saying this thing almost
explicitly
this left-wing group together rising
says there is no such thing as other
people's kids they wrote quote today
together rising is investing 150 000
in three trusted organizations serving
lgbtqi2s plus i didn't make that up
that's actually what they call it now
youth in florida they're providing
critical mental health support vital
medical care school resources and
housing support services across florida
there is no such thing as other people's
children
the slippery slope gets even slipperier
remember hillary clinton wrote a book it
was called it takes a village
she had this expression it takes a
village to raise a child it's a common
expression
well within what 20 years we've gone
from it takes a village to raise a child
your child is not merely raised by the
individual two
there is no such thing as other people's
children in other words you have no
right to raise your own child
we
the genius liberal ruling class we have
100 the right to raise your child
and unfortunately
look on the surface this is completely
insane again if you tell me that you're
going to come here and take my child and
raise my child the way that you creepy
perverts see fit instead of the way i
want to raise my child in the correct
way uh start running you don't come
knocking on my door and expect things to
go just fine okay that's not going to
turn out well for you but on a deeper
level
there is something kind of true about
this
not even
to say that it should be this way just
this is the way it is
your children will be raised in large
part by the culture that they're living
in
regardless of what you want
you could be the most upright ordinary
upstanding citizen but if you live in a
debauched and decadent culture that is
going to affect the way your kids are
raised it really does take a village to
raise a child because your kids are
seeing other people they're very often
being educated by other people even if
they're homeschooled they're going to be
educated by other people they're going
to see neighbors they're going to see
people at the restaurant they're going
to see friends of friends and extended
family members okay and that's going to
have an impact
so
yes a culture
that holds that boys can be girls as a
sacred truth
it's neither sacred nor true but if the
culture holds it as a sacred truth that
is going to influence the way your kids
are raised which is why it's more
important now than ever
to assert our political power and retake
those standards and say no hey hold up i
know that you kooks who have a lot of
institutional power in america i know
that you pretend that men are women but
they're not and we're not going to let
you say that
it's just not true
and sorry we're going to push back
that's what you're seeing in the parents
movement against critical race theory
against transgenderism this is the
movement that swept glen younkin into
power in virginia
even democrats are now realizing this
does not sell very well beto o'rourke
the candidate who can't stop running for
office even beto or work is admitting no
okay we're not going to be pushing this
stuff in schools
and i think you and i probably are both
on the same page as well
we we don't uh see crt being taught in
our schools right now it is it's a
course that is taught in law school
no i don't think it should be taught in
in our schools yeah
so beta or work starts off with the
typical democrat evasion line critical
race theory is not being taught in our
schools critical race theory is it's
just a course taught in law school which
he doesn't know what he's talking about
about this or anything else but what he
means is critical race theory as an
academic lens
began really in harvard law school about
35 years ago at 40 years ago now about
35 years ago and
it was this idea that america is
hopelessly racist
that white supremacy
and racism are structural in america
very often you don't even see it
and so
you uh this imbues every other field
with this new kind of knowledge it is
not so much its own course
as it is a gadfly on other systems it
derives from critical theory and
critical studies and one of the
sympathetic historians of critical
theory
martin j
says that it's really a gadfly in other
systems so when when we say critical
race theory is being taught we're not
saying that there's a course in in some
elementary school called critical race
theory you know okay kids i hope you
enjoyed social studies now you're going
to your critical race theory class
that's not how it works but the way
critical race theory and the other
critical theory
disciplines work and derivations work is
they just glom onto literature they glom
onto
history they glom on to social studies
for goodness sake they can glom onto
math okay they can glum onto basically
every other department and that's what
we're talking about here so beta
o'rourke's excuse doesn't hold water the
parents know it doesn't hold water and
then they say well do you think it
should be taught in schools and beto
says no i do not
and there it is
okay now he'll try to weasel out of it
beta or work doesn't believe anything
beta or work is just some idiot
narcissist who wants to skateboard
around whataburger parking lots and just
get elected to be a congressman or to be
a senator or to be the president i don't
think he believes a damn thing at all
he's just a completely empty suit he is
he's like
robert redford in the candidate except
he believes even less okay and he's much
less attractive so
but he's saying this now because he
knows that parents hate this crap
okay really bad news for democrats
they've just gone way too far and even
beto hell yes i'm going to take your
ar-15s even that guy is saying whoa
hell yes i'm a social conservative now
texas please elect me
why be because he knows that what
parents want their kids to be taught in
school is not crazy gender theory it's
not crazy racial theory it's
math
it's arithmetic and reading and writing
and really basic stuff that kids are not
being taught if you talk to an average
inner city student in a public school
right now they could probably tell you
something about racism
structural racism
inequality they could probably tell you
about the difference between transgender
and cisgender and
other genders
but they probably couldn't read
okay and that's a big problem there's a
new study that just came out of maryland
in terms of kids academic outcomes
it is an indictment of our entire
education system
a full 85 percent of students in
maryland
85
are not proficient in math
a lot of this has to do with covid
according to this study because you took
kids out of school for two years what do
you think is going to happen
the kids already weren't doing well in
school when they were showing up and
doing their homework
now they're terrible
this is a quote stunning amount of
learning laws according to experts who
are looking at these studies
in baltimore city
less than seven percent of students who
were tested in third through fifth grade
math scored proficient
93 of these students are not proficient
in math
the results for english language arts
are just as bad so you're not even
saying well look math is hard but at
least the kids can kind of fuss their
way around in english or history no 91
of students tested in third through
fifth grade are not proficient in
language
they can't read and write and speak
for middle schoolers in baltimore 95 who
took the 7th and 8th grade tests were
not proficient in math
across the state so look baltimore is a
city with a lot of challenges even
across the state 94 were not proficient
at math at those grade levels
at one baltimore high school 77 of
students were found to read at an
elementary or kindergarten level this is
in high school this is more than three
quarters of the students
as a result of the coveted closures
in 10 baltimore public high schools
students earned below a 1.0
gpa
and then the craziest part is these kids
are failing they don't know anything
they can't read they can't they can
barely talk
they don't stay back at grade they just
keep getting passed on because the
situation is so dire that repeating the
ninth grade isn't going to do anything
for them
eventually the bill comes due i remember
you probably you might not remember this
now but i remember it really clearly
those first two weeks of covid were sort
of fun
they were fun in the way that
a uh a rainstorm that takes the power
out is fun you're in your apartment
building oh we're all in this together
you're in your house and where the power
goes out and maybe you got to go over to
your neighbor and get a flashlight oh
this is kind of fun
snow day oh great we don't have to go to
school tomorrow that's kind of fun
but it's not free you can't just take
two years off of life and expect the
bill not to come due but that's what the
democrats expected
they expected that well certainly with
kovit they thought okay we can shut down
the economy for two years and it'll be
fine
we won't have crazy inflation we'll just
pay people to do nothing but we won't
have wild crazy inflation right
we can take kids out of school for two
years and that's fine that won't affect
their test scores right
really they've taken kids out of school
in terms of really good substantive
education for about 40 years now that's
fine that won't matter
we cannot teach kids anything
and still have a really good country
right no then you're gonna get a vice
president who doesn't know which
countries are in nato while she's
touring nato
uh you know
to discuss a war that is largely about
nato
and by the way you know the craziest
part
it's it's not over
it's not over this whole this whole
covid thing that was the cause of a lot
of these economic and educational
problems
it's not over they're trying to convince
you it's over because it's really bad
for their poll numbers
and because they're now focused on this
war in ukraine
but it's still it's still cropping back
up there's a new news story new omicron
variant surging
states across the us are removing
mandates for masks with hawaii set to be
the last on march 26th but scientists
say removing a stealth omicron variant
ba2
or rather a stealth omicron marine ba2
has been moving steadily across the
country uh-oh
it now makes up 11.6 of overall virus
cases as of march 5th since it began
doubling on february 5th it keeps
cropping up and and cases have doubled
the past few weeks uh oh here we go what
about the tsa
one of the last mass mandates that still
exists is on airplanes when are we going
to lose that well the tsa just decided
to extend it they're going to extend it
a month longer that'll probably only be
a month right that's how this works just
one more month just one more month to
slow the spread right no they're they're
pulling back a little bit on kovid to
get their their
numbers back up because the covet is now
a net negative not a net positive for
the democrats but they don't actually
want to give up the power and so they're
not giving up the power they're still
holding on to it joe biden is not
getting rid of the emergency declaration
they took fouchi off tv because fauci
became a net negative for them instead
of a net positive but he's still got the
power all these technocrats still have
all the power that they took from you
for the past two years and they are
waiting to use it again they're even
setting the stage to use it again oh
here comes the other omicron uh-oh in
ukraine you might have other pathogens
breaking out get ready get ready
the only way we're going to get our
power back our constitutional
republic back is if we demand it and we
take it back and we use the political
power that we've got the reset is moving
on and they keep moving the goal post
senator jeff merkley this democrat
senator went on chris hayes show on
msnbc last week and you can see them
moving the goal posts on energy
it's not a question of where the actual
stuff comes from it's fossil fuels price
on a global market subject to these kind
of things
this idea that we can drill our way out
of this is been proven to be madness do
do your colleagues understand this
as long as there is a world market for
oil russia will be able to to sell its
oil and so unfortunately not all my
colleagues yet understand that the way
to undercut the power of russia is to
end our dependence on oil and and have
the world transition to renewable energy
so hold on so
here and they go on in this interview
they keep conflating two goals one of
the goals is bring down the cost of
energy the other goal is punish vladimir
putin
and right now the
those goals are in conflict because the
more we punish putin the more expensive
gas becomes but putin still probably
almost certainly going to survive it
because europe is addicted to his gas
because of western energy policies that
have rolled out the red carpet for putin
specifically the policies of joe biden
so
the question you have to ask is what are
we really aiming at here do we want to i
also love that he talks about how we
need renewable energy because we don't
want to be beholden to the oil market as
though renewable energy doesn't have a
market too all of these things are
driven in large part by market dynamics
but the question is what do we want to
do do we want to drive down energy costs
do we want to punish vladimir putin what
is the point of punishing vladimir putin
what's the end goal of that other than
just making ourselves feel good we don't
have the answers to any of those
questions and so we're not really doing
any of it
at this point
the unintended consequences of a lot of
our russia policies are to ensconce
putin more firmly in power the
unintended consequences frankly who
knows may be intended by these idiots
who are running our country in the state
department and the white house under joe
biden is to create incentives for joe
biden to invade ukraine the uh
unintended or perhaps intended
consequences of our energy policy is to
raise the cost of energy here in america
without any purpose without even helping
the environment because we're just
burning oil from iran potentially from
venezuela and from russia
before you do things that just make you
feel good that make you just sound good
you've got to ask what is it for what is
it actually going to accomplish what are
the basic elements of the policy that i
am pursuing our ruling class can't
answer any of that and so you can't
expect things to get any better
certainly not under the people running
the show right now i'm michael knowles
the michael knowles shall see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire
on today's episode civilian casualties
mount from the ongoing russian assault
we hear from our reporter on the ground
in ukraine and polling shows a seismic
shift taking place ahead of the midterms
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
bye